faker is
back of course he never really went away
he still leaks goat but this morning he
broke a record which he himself set back
in 2015 at a time when he became the
unkillable demon king for seven years
nobody could touch this record for seven
years everybody wondered who could
actually beat it and for seven years the
answer
was him
[Music]
all right then in a few seconds i'm
about to be shrunk onto a small phone
which means it's time to tell you guys
to subscribe to the channel and hit the
notification bell if you haven't done so
already that's just what happens when
you get shrunk onto a small phone
it will happen to you too if you're even
vaguely aware of league of legends
you'll know faker since bursting onto
the scene nine years ago he set the bar
for what it takes to be the very best
oh man
he's gonna jump back in though after the
wild growth he needs to get out of there
though oh baker hits another beautiful
spear
and don't worry i'm not gonna play that
clip you know what i mean what was that
but his trophy cabinet speaks for itself
he's won lck nine times he's bagged
himself two msi titles and of course
he's been world champion and astounding
three separate times between 2013 and
2017 skt now known as t1 often look the
favorites to go all the way in any
international tournament since then
although faker's name has continued to
be in any conversation of the world's
elite players other names have taken
some of that spotlight recently though
t1 and faker seem to have developed some
sort of medical condition which means
they are incapable of losing since
january they've been too owing every
single week sometimes you think surely
the streak ends here but no they always
come out on top the result is that after
beating quang dong freaks this morning
in week 9 of the lck t1 are sitting at a
record-breaking 15 wins and zero losses
and that's gonna do it t1 will take down
the nexus and make history tonight with
their 15th win in a row at the lck
to be clear
nobody nobody has managed to do this in
the history of the lck the previous
record of 14-0 was set way back in 2015
by faker on sk telecom although if you
watch my intro you'd know that but the
headline here is that after all these
years faker has kind of taken back the
crown
from himself now the question is can t1
and faker go all the way and do
something we've never seen in the lck a
perfect 18-0 split it's something we've
seen in other regions before i'll never
forget fnatic's monstrous summer 2015 in
europe where they went undefeated for
the entire split and now faker and t1
look to write their names into the
history books in much the same way one
of the things i find impressive about
this t1 roster is just how young they
are they're one of the youngest teams in
the league with an average age of just
20. that drops to 18 if you take faker
out it's weird to wrap your head around
that if like me you remember faker as a
rookie but he's one of the old geezers
now in the lck he often finds his
teammates five or six years younger than
him this has helped spawn some pretty
incredible memes like this one which
helped convey a great point about faker
and t1 he might be older than his
teammates his highlight reels might
focus on his plays from five years ago
but somehow
faker looks like he's getting stronger
again at least that's what it seems now
there could be any number of reasons for
this unparalleled success first off
faker seems to have really grown into
his leadership role check out this clip
from last summer a faker explaining to
kumayushi why you really shouldn't talk
during a pause
credit needs to be given to the rest of
the team of course for example
is a monster that's proven to be an
incredible homegrown success story for
the org over the past three years after
spending much of that time as a trainee
and sub as t1 needs to play this
perfectly the flame chompers they come
forward the crush is there as
connect well is gonna get taken down and
now faker's in for the cleanup the
rockets will land and i have no idea in
hell how t1 did that also the meta kind
of suits faker right now he's been able
to play a lot of leblanc this split and
we all know just how disgusting he is on
that champ but we've also got to see him
on other old faithfuls such as azir and
a reworked arri now i used to watch
faker play arry
years ago i used to learn lows from him
i don't want to say how many years ago
that was but the point is he hasn't lost
it while faker looks to keep this insane
win streak going he's also been knocking
down some personal milestones too in
early march he hit two and a half
thousand career kills in the lck over
twice as much as some other people on
the top 15 leaderboard and this came
less than a month after he celebrated an
astounding 1 000 games in the lck being
only second to this record to deft who
incredibly actually achieved it the day
before faker the point is things seem to
be coming together for faker at the
moment he's dominating these
leaderboards of the all-time korean
greats but the difference between him
and a lot of them is he's still going
faker has always had natural skill but
the past few years have also shown what
a stable leader he can be for the young
talent that surrounds him he's been to
the mountaintop quite a few times
actually nobody has seen more success
than him in league of legends any young
player that plays with him is naturally
going to absorb some of that experience
and mentality after world's last year
faker committed to t1 for the entirety
of 2022 so we know he's going to be with
them and continue playing for at least
this year but what happens after that
any conversation about faker's longevity
always includes speculation about when
this superhuman is finally gonna pack it
in and retire let me tell you there
aren't many pros from 2013 still
knocking about now romantics will always
say faker will never retire until he
wins worlds one final time now a year or
two ago i would have laughed at that but
now
maybe not worlds this year will mark six
years since faker last lifted its trophy
it's been six years of shifting metas
new korean dynasties the domination of
china and europe showing up at times not
to mention minor regions drawing some
serious blood sure you could never
really write faker off during this time
but now especially with this record
being broken things feel a bit different
ltk playoffs are right around the corner
and i highly encourage you to join me in
watching them because i truly think we
might be witnessing the return of the
king here i don't want to get too
carried away here obviously i know it's
only march but
but if faker does win worlds this year
and then he retires you're going to want
to say you were here for it
okay
oh that kind of hurt my eyes